peu
[Musique]
c'est quand même fantastique faire sa
toilette c'est moi qui frappe
il ya une heure que chacun pourra voir
la salle de bain c'est papa qui est à
l'intérieur ou quatre en moins fort tu
me salis sera le pied alors c'est pour
aujourd'hui alors
bonsoir peu comme un seuil à la borne
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un là sûrement quelqu'un se
fermer je suis pas sourde
fort
non j'ai pu observer chapelle rien c'est
peut-être monsieur george george
pourquoi georges ba il est tout le temps
là savoure car non mais moi je le trouve
gentil monsieur je reviens à la place de
mademoiselle cheveux bien ce que fera et
il se peut même plus grand bond
une vie de daniel je suis beau s'excuser
pas mais moi je suis habitué à
rencontrer si les amis de mes enfants à
toute heure du jour et de la nuit
je peux vous êtes jeudi qu'elle ait rien
sur la pause et bien d'autres jeunes
croyez moi n'était jamais rien les
crèmes les pompes a élargi ses ports 10
ans et se méfie vous savez mais ici
personne ne m'écoute d'aniane ton ami de
daniel tu n'es pas raisonnables en cette
info sont insupportables tous les matins
c'est la même que média qui prendra la
scène de bain qu'est ce que je vous
disais oui koné côte de beauté abîme la
pouf de regarder dominique vous avez du
cinéma eh bien on l'obligé à s'enduire
le visage avec des horreurs
vous connaissez dominique bien entendu
tout on essaie pas de minuit nous quel
dommage arlene est-ce que même moi
dominique et éveillé non madame gelé
paru ce matin
tant pis j'aurais bien aimé mademoiselle
mais j'ai oublié nous demander comment
vous vous appeliez pinky je trouve que
les chattes maintenant mais charmant
j'aurais bien aimé que vous rencontriez
parce que vous m'auriez donner votre
avis croyez mademoiselle une vraie jeune
fille est ce que vous comprenez ce que
je veux dire alors qu ils vous
mademoiselle une vraie jeune fille plus
vers une carrière au cinéma ans
conduisant honnêtement vous avez entendu
lire de ce milieu était un petit peu
enfin il paraît que les jeunes filles
subissent parfois des pressions gênante
vous voyez ce que je me dis
oui je crois eh bien je serais désolé
qu'il arrive quelque chose à dominique
celui-ci gentil petit à la voilà qui
s'éveille ne vous connaissent pas oui
vous avez de gros 70 françois même fait
mon préféré vous savez les autres mappus
souvent de favoritisme mais c'est mon
préféré vous allégez un grave problème
avec lui aussi oui vous je crains que
l'atmosphère de ces caves où il va jouer
le soir ne soit pas bonne pour ce petit
mot mais que faire il est tellement la
musique écoutée luxe un joueur tu me
daniel ton ami tu attends cette loi dans
le but de lui faire madame oui j'ai pu
draps pour changer même modèle daniel
mais commence la machette en une vaste
île devant dieu ché pa je peux vous en
faisons consommation extraordinaire
enfin il boîtant récit de vous prendre
en main le dossier au grenier
bon j'y vais je suis là je comprendrais
ça plus tard ça vous arrivera à tout de
suite n'est ce pas
françois
or mme anne sophie ses moyens mais cette
folle alors vous voulez la faire courir
j'ai cru bien faire
vous avez trop car faire des spaghettis
à sophie mais vous ne savez pas que les
tortues sont herbivores rbi quoi ça ne
marche pas tu vas getty horny bifteck
non plus bas c'est quand même malheureux
elle a failli s'étouffer
si je n'étais pas revenu à temps et puis
elle était mouillée comment ça se
faisait madame qui m'a dit la baigner
oui elle sentait mauvais alors je vais
un peu lessivé vous attaquerons fait ce
phénomène est si oui même qu'elle a
l'air de bien l'aimer ça oui ça nous met
chef qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont fait maman
oui tout moment et ont grogné pas nous
attendre
quelle bande de sauvages alors ok
oui
comme ma vieille dame qui compte à
régler un petit me dire où est passé le
carnet où je marque mes comptes de poker
c'est brouillon richmond à la pêche de
prix je suis appelé aux mets tu veux
bien répondre à mes questions tu veux
bien mon petit carnet de poker tu
n'aurais pas vu par hasard genou à la
pêche s'est dit ça fait peur en tout cas
je vais te faire mal il savait que
plusieurs oiseaux chanter n'est ce pas
tu penses tu pas là pour apporter sa
puissance en prenant soin de les lister
oui c'est un bon test aurait fêté ses
salles en attendant avec deux piles et
le nombre et la même énergie à quoi
celle là se renforcer pour revoir madame
vous à des niveaux non non non non mais
on va être inquiète
vous trouvez vous que ces enfants sont
turbulents
le sport georges bertret mon visage
bonjour matane à georges je suis dans un
état
les enfants viennent encore de sushis
poster familles n'ont pas daniel lampart
votre petit daniel joue jc que ces types
qui moi j'adore désordre qu'ils sont
encore capables de rougir
vous avez mon petit françois ça lui
arrivait souvent autrefois soit
maintenant c'est fini mais vous ne dites
rien georges vous veniez voir daniel oui
je pensais qu'elle serait la wii
eh bien non
vous l'avez mentez et lavezzi pendant
que de morges et les terribles savait
hélas comme si toute la matinée dans la
salle de bal et autres étaient furieux
ils se sont battus si vous aviez vu sa
bombe
ça ne fait rien je reviendrai elle
s'envolera vraiment vous n'avez pas de
change
moi je suis fille de daniel qui est en
moi je me demande comment un garçon posé
comme vous avez s'intéresser de
pareilles écervelés mais si si si je
vous assure georges
je n'ai pas l'habitude de faire des
compliments mais je trouve que vous êtes
absolument charmant donnez vous êtes oui
oui vous le prétendez en titre
et comment vont les affaires vous êtes
content où on va ça marche à peu près je
ne me plains pas avec tous ces accidents
tout le monde doit s'assurer maintenant
non non ne croyez pas cela non non là la
plupart des gens sont très mal assurée
wallon alors élevé de contestations
après les sinistres nous ça vous est
également pourvu qu'ils s'assurent à
votre compagnie non non pas du tout non
nous n'avons absolument pas intérêt à ce
qu'il ya des mécontents vous savez non
non non il faut voir les choses plus
largement aujourd'hui vous voyez vous
madame
les clients sont souvent difficiles à
comprendre
il n'écoute pas toujours nos conseils je
vais vous donner un exemple
et bien non charge parce qu'il est très
tard c'est mon mari m'a fait une scène
épouvantable ce matin qu'est ce qui est
absolument à ce que nous nous mettions à
table à l'heure les affaires vous
comprenez ça ou harlan madame
est-ce que vous rappeler ce qu'est
monsieur ce matin oui madame c'est vrai
on passait très bien
bon eh bien je vais m'en aller
eh bien ces [ __ ]
les ateliers vous êtes venu soyez sans
crainte
or par l'or mais hommage aux hommes
excusez-moi de vous avoir dérangé mais
vous êtes toujours le bienvenu dans
cette maison et vous savez bien
ouais ça
oui monsieur
c'est vous qui jouez de la guitare
oui m'assieds bombasse avait
immédiatement le national mais voilà si
monsieur alors sur youtube via monsieur
bonjour bonsoir les polars
la mairie je n'en sais rien mais je n'ai
pas fait ça grandit acheter au prix
imbattable
mes chers amis je n'aime pas quand vous
m'appelez ma chère amie quand vous
commencez comme ça c'est toujours pour
me dire des choses désagréables
vous avez vu ça ben vous le voyez bien
c'est la note de l'étier viala qui vous
étonne lettre dont on pourrait taper ses
notes de la machine
c'est tout ce que vous trouvez à dire
800 litres de lait pour le mois
pour sept personnes six exactement
puisque dominique nawapa non les faits
beaucoup
non non non il n'y a pas d'erreur il ya
simplement dans cette maison un
incroyable gaspillage quand est ce que
je vous dis un incroyable gaspillage par
mail vous m'expliquer je vous prie
comment on peut consommer 800 litres de
lait dans un mois si personne en prenant
des bas bon il y en a peut-être bien
qu'ils se servent du lait pour faire
leurs allusions à rappeler sion j'ai
bien dormi
bonjour mr
et ça 74 boucher au chocolat chez
boulanger c'est insensé
son corps sans vie de m elle met get
more c'est une formule un peu plus rien
réparation dans cette maison voix soit
itunes et patates en 30 secondes tu
pourras les restaurants record taquiner
raser les jambes avec paris je vous
préviens premier je trouve en face à
servir le rasoir je lui rentre dedans on
attend c'est moi qui paierait la fuite
âge là parce que c'est l'avant du poil
aux pattes d'oie médicaux à nous feront
l'honneur de faire ta g 7 mai croppi
temps ce cher ami tu perds la vente et
au régime car en drapé les tigres et
compagnie on achète et vend des sites et
à ça j'ai juste trouvé dans gens il est
à jeun il a fini arlene des jeunes pop
mais nous mange que le cochon je
rappelle de mon témoignage
c'est à toi ma conduite cuites mais vous
êtes folle est le fait d'un montage et
trois touchés
en les pommes de terre ou des pommes de
terre après c'est une star elle se
nourrit pas tâche facile mais d'aller ne
rentre pas déjeuner chez elle et la
france sont même passés dès jeudi si ça
continue je me dis pourquoi d'ailleurs
ne l'était pas déjeuné ce que je sais
moi je ne suis pas chargé de la
surveiller abishag 12
j'aimerais de temps en temps pouvoir
faire un repas tranquille andré c'est
une idée malade elle joue bien certaine
qu'elle n'est pas mourant demander du dr
cohen a mangé de boucher au chocolat ce
matin 74 ans après bamako par autant mon
petit grand mère oui vous savez andré
c'est moi qui prends les boucheries
nombre de qui c'est pour mon goûter des
mamans il fallait le dire
les enfants ont déjà dépensé un contrat
pour leurs méfaits impunis stock nommé
mauvaise haleine combien de fois
avez-vous dit les attendre
et de toute façon vous devez pas du
sport leveaux
mais madame visite à elle que je cerne
toute opposition
jan adam alors je dors oui c'est ça
il ya longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu george
dans cette maison d'ailleurs il était là
ce matin jours fous d'amour de
minuscules le chantent enfin du tout le
monde c'est tout on ne sait jamais
comment cela peut finir que tu veux dire
quand même pas parler de quelque chose
ou pas sont eux rassemblés ici
tiens c'est curieux c'est en ratissant
quelque chose de bizarre et pas on
dirait de l'acétone vous voyez bien que
c'est bien de nous
dominique je vous ferai la charmille
allait continuer votre toilette un peu
plus loin tu n'aimes pas l'honneur du
vernis pas avec le beau nom
danic est ce que tu la manges et vient
pleurer des peines de coeur a présenté
par sidonie peur jamais qu est ce qu ont
pu à montrer maman je tiens avertir qu à
partir d'aujourd'hui si quelqu'un qui
que ce soit touche tu entends touche à
sophie jeter mallet de plantes grasses
parfaitement sous jacent c'est ce matin
vous savez ce qu'on a fait on a passé à
sofia l'autre apple
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit elle a dit qu'à
la fin ils creusèrent vous avez de la
chance qu'elle soit solide
ça ça je peux vous dire ça va vraiment
barder et peut-on savoir pourquoi il
devient impossible d'entrer dans la
salle de bal mata maintenant donc fameux
tirs et cueilli résister platine et
qu'est ce que tu dis ma portée en
moyenne qu'à me dit ça alors c'est la
pause fort je n'ai pas pu y entrer une
seconde tu en feras ce n'est pas nous
les pieux l'alignement pas tous genres
est ton ami pink est attendu pendant
qu'elle dort ici montant moyen moyen d
expression chère près de chez nous
appartient je vous jure que si j'arrive
à entrer dans la salle de bain de ma
batteur vous n'êtes pas près troyes bat
toilettes mais parce que ce que nous
verrons
qu'est-ce qui fait la loi ici je
voudrais bien savoir si quelqu'un
s'amuse de s'enflammer dans la salle
dommage je défonce la porte
d'ailleurs c'est bien simple j'ai fait
enlever latarjet
là
vous croyez que ça va continuer comme ça
vous vous trompez non mais j'en ai tout
entendu la c3 traitant qui n'ont rien à
fiche de la journée pour un match à dire
la salle de bain la paix sérieux sont
jamais d'interdire la salle de bain
maure et plus à autre chose j'ai dit que
ce qui ne serait pas là - le caire ne
déjeune rep ah vous avez un peu trop
tendance les uns et les autres à
considérer cette maison comme un
restaurant il va falloir que ça change
écoute ma paie un loyer n'a pas nommé
papa qui tiennent à partir de demain
matin du fait maison à quiconque arrive
en salles bien d'accord avec lé déjeuner
chez vos copains chez vos copines
puisqu'il n'ya qu'eux qui cote
grand-mère de cette marque est qu'aucun
des amis à toi ça va parce qu'à la belle
jambe à la piscine était close après
jamais vu une bande de cinglés pareil
celui là c'est pas son temps dans les
égouts à jouer de la trompette c'est
quoi
youtube c'est cool non qui n'a pas en
cas se bichonner ses lacets météores ont
cette fois passer ici que pour se
précipiter dans sa chambre suivie par
les dosettes de copains a traîné quoi
pas une bande de petits voiliers n'a
rien à dire de m'éclate il me connaît
même pas les trois manches contre eux
[Musique]
votre coeur est très fatigué en ce
moment et ce pendant de commencer par
vous gérez bien regarder tout autour de
vous à quoi ressemble cette maison je
vous répondrai que tu as joué daniel je
signale que la barrique de beaucoup est
arrivé
n'étant pas actuellement c'est moi qui
ai lu la rentrée françois tu me parles
plaisir de la descendre à la cave alain
karlen que tu sois moi quelque chose au
moins une fois dans ta vie mais le
ballon est fausse et des brûlures à 120
cm 42 corps pendant tout l'été la
gazette facile à dire mais si la corde
casse moi je me retrouve en baisse ou la
barrique je ne te dit pas assez mais
quand on marque le futur car d'en haut
avec allen ne citerai nous vous
inquiétez pas une classe unique les
matins je suis pas mort
avec le talent d'un idiot son talent
avec deux cordes et tout seul on peut
s'y trompera content d'être passé mois
300 kg alors tu l'as fait descendre
marche par marche
en fait je complète pas haïr et montpon
26 janvier mais traite ou si vous voulez
mais je n'engagerai personnes pour faire
ce travail
timothy cheek place à ben mosbah pendant
toute l'année non non non mais rentrez
descendra en tout cas non chérie tu
mettras poelvoorde qu'avec glacial
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on aura parfois
tu veux être un coup de coeur comme
ennemi et puis je ferai bien ta tion et
se tord au trésor est ce que madame
monsieur part de la ville là demain au
oui ça y est le plus tôt parce que
madame demain samedi soir vous venez pas
avec nous il ya un récital de guitare
bon ben voilà alors faites comme vous
voulez y aller mais que ceux qui
viennent trois combats cij a régné les
clans valises et je vous invite que je
ne serai pas une minute en double file
qui viendra avec nous ce soir
wow j'ai du boulot tu peux aussi bien
travailler là bas mon chéri tu deviennes
comme vous le pensez pas sérieusement à
priver votre fils de sa principale
séance de vocalys en ce que tu peux être
des bonnets mon bon père violent mais
nous ferons soit on doit gagner tu
viendras mais c'est bien la première
fois qu'il y aura encore
aucune en pis nous irons là bas tous les
deux n'est ce pas vrai en amoureux des
manchots tu toi tu seras gentil avec ta
grand mère s'il a besoin de quelque
chose vous inquiétez pas pour moi chaque
fois là et on sera plus rock que je suis
invité un pique nique un peu que vous
voyez alors elle n'a pas droit de
rigoler un peu non
françois je t'ai fait d'être correct
avec la grand-mère ne pas dire ou es du
mot à la bouche pleine et moi c'est toi
qui les a pris tu te défends toucha met
à faire du mans temps je te l'interdît
alors ça m'atteint pas singles et non tu
sais combien chose qu'est ce que tu veux
que je refasse n'était pas de votre 45
c'est parti tout seul ça fait super
maman qu'ils appelaient pour aller aux
femmes n irons mais c'est je suis alors
c'est moi qui les ai pris qui s'est
prêté à une copine de quoi elle est
invitée à une soirée tu vas pas en faire
un drame en soirée je lui ai répondu tu
veux dire avec notamment paraît qu'ils
veulent quand même positive et ses
dépens marlène harlem non mais on croit
rêver dans cette maison traqué mais plus
joli soutien italien à une vitesse je ne
connais même pas ça va je veux pas nous
casser les pieds toute la semaine à
quelques chaussures
mettez un certain culot pour voir la
tête qui fait vivre de touche à ses
disques on veut seulement
ils sont foutus
d'orange et je n'ai pas compris le
message
mais nous arrange leur sujet pour s'en
servir l annonce en scène le prête pas
m'en fiche j'ai pas entrer dans ces
considérations il a pas eu touché un
point c'est tout si elle d'être axé
potocki mon père a en tout cas pas sur
moi d'apporter ses trench town
achèterait un 9 7 pour open grand mère
son rasoir subira le même sort que les
autres dont tiens tu me fais une
cigarette
non je n'ai que ça
[Musique]
c'est ce qui est arrivé à madame
christine on est mort la bagnole
couchent dehors en ce moment oui
pourquoi parce que j'ai un copain qui
acheta locale oui alors on pourra
peut-être la bête chez lui fit anciens
presque jamais le soir et le soir j'ai à
galoper aux diables wallon moi je tenais
en touraine tu fais ça forte possible
comme c'est gentil mais content pour mon
papa parce que tu fais semblant de
rentrer la voiture et 15 heures du matin
on la trouvera encore du côté de la
huchette tu prends pour un idiot
d'anciens mercredi soir
comment veux tu que je sache ce que je
fais mercredi soir non parce que ça
m'arrangerait que tu me la posent les
accusons caplanne bon c'est ça à chaque
fois que demande cette bagnole manquent
pas pour les acquis sont implantées un
sombre crétin de méconnaissance peut
s'arranger pas chaque fois qu'il sort
pour laisser le contact s'est tu pars ça
m'est arrivé une fois une fois très tôt
de la bande raconte je n'ai rien à
raconter ça suffit chacun occupant cette
voiture dans la semaine qui suit comme
par enchantement
je souhaitais vous êtes de bv c'est
curieux non les douzaines de +22 marche
but
les cendriers sont clos et 2 mai
complète rouge à lèvres les tapis sont
dégoûtants chaque voiture n'est tout de
même pas un
la semaine dernière j'ai trouvé une
bouteille de whisky souhait banquet toi
tu finiras par toutes manquées dans un
platane et ta mère me frappe chez nombre
bon j'ai compris tu sais pas un et ben
si ça vous amuse et pour ne pas en plus
d'ailleurs que touche à celle que j'ai
commandé on verra à 4 heures du matin
tout va bien tous couché a fait plutôt
du doigt par la tête que tu es mon
programme et à des théories
je ne sais pas ce que tu veux avec en ce
moment dix étrangers qui fait mille
épouvantable pourquoi pas je vous en
prie 102 minutes sur nos missions vous
écouter juste avant qu'on laisse un
homme si t'arrives est plus malin toi tu
es qui ne passait pas l'heure mais dans
des boîtes à souffler dans des
trompettes
regardez ça me regarde non j'ai pris 15
ans essentiellement l'âge de raison en
fait dans ce qu'il te plaît
mais a prévenu le bien plus me casser
les oreilles avec ta musique de sauvage
encore ma musique de sauvage et baky
koné vous avez andréa dubourg
je sais je sais pas quand mais oui
armstrong est un génie et jean sébastien
bach le dernier des enfants qui est en
place qui est une connerie tu as un beau
soir c'est moi
bakar est un cmos sensationnel mais
c'est parfait d' le soir jouent du club
sainte l'ipev pour comprendre la
cornemuse
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils ont pourquoi
vous avez l'impression de les avoir
quelquefois tenue
vous dire bon rien le coup je vous dise
il rappelle sur nes et faire leurs
quatre volontés
vous ne pensez pas qu'ils vont changer
comme ça brusquement du jour au
lendemain sous prétexte que vous
éprouvez soudain le besoin trop respecté
andré tout ça juste est-ce que je n'ai
pas toujours c'est bon de voir avec vous
pouvez me rapprocher quelque chose à ce
sujet fait beaucoup de chaleur je sais
que nous avons avec les adorer il aurait
mieux valu les élever vous avez passé le
plus clair de notre temps elle et
dorlotés 1,9 et les punitions ne vous
souvenez pas les dégâts toi cachette
quand je les avait privés de déchets
landrais aujourd'hui on prive plus les
enfants ne dessert les éducateurs
moddeurs et séducteur modernes ont pu au
dernier oui
les éducateurs bon dernier déjà les
résultats vous tombez pas ils se fichent
de vous toute la journée ils vivent
complètement à part et vous ne les
connaissez pas plus si vous les voyez
pour la première fois à ses remarquables
renard cap voyons andré ne soyez pas si
sévère
voyons en raid il faut les laisser
s'épanouir c'est pas louis mettre quoi
vous plaignez-vous dont ils sont en
plein épanouissement
oui bien sûr mais pas vincent ce que je
voudrais envoyer la manière forte en
andré on est déchu les enfants comme
autrefois on s'adresse à leur
intelligence leur sensibilité on
n'allait pas recommencer je ne connais
vos théories c'est tolérable
je vous fais grâce des détails je suis
peut-être rétrograde dépassé tout ce que
vous voudrez mais pour moi le plus beau
raisonnement n'aura jamais une bonne
rasade bien sûr que vous avez toi non
non non rien du tout qu'est ce qui te
cacher que françois s'en aller faire le
pitre tous les soirs à saint germain 26
s je vous assure andré il suit des
conférences de confiance
les gels troisième en nombre commencez
pas à pleurnicher
c'est tout ce que vous avez trouvé de
mieux à faire quand vous vous sentez
dépassé par les événements je voudrais
tellement bien fait enfin lycée quoi
rime cette scène voudriez reprendront c3
idiome vous ne pensez pas qu'il est un
peu tard alors qu'est ce que vous voulez
vous de recul
si vous croyez qu'ils ont tant de
s'occuper de leurs sentiments
c'est pas le moment ils en sont au stade
des sensations c'est captivant cette
époque de l'industrie c'est comme pour
moi il ne m'adresse la parole que pour
me demander de l'argent ou pour
d'emprunter la voiture et quand je ne
serai plus l'amour est ce que je vous
dis donc du bien de moi c'est leur
donnant au moins d'illusions d'avoir
aimé leur père alors c'est vous qui êtes
une épouvantable sentimentale ma parole
on dirait que vous avez des as en danger
a indiqué m on comprenait pas je
voudrais vous rapprocher de les aider
c'est normal que voulez-vous que je vous
dise où est attendue une occasion à
l'aide du maître saulnier d'appel du
poids des études de françois tonner j'ai
nettement l'impression qu'ils ne met pas
les pieds à la faculté en ce moment là
fait en vrai comment pouvez vous dire
une chose pareille
pour maurice décidément je crois que
vous êtes un peuple à ce soir merci
françois
françois je me défends immédiatement
soir
tu vas me jurez mais tu m'entends ne
jurez que tu ne manques pas à la faculté
en ce moment non ça va pas recommencer
très grave
battus ces moments moi j'ai autre chose
à des écouteurs banyala l'a attrapé un
moineau qu'est ce qu'on va lui donner à
manger
non tu viens pas du tout non tu sais pas
ce que c'est qu'un moineau banon
non un moineau en langage courant c'est
un mouflet c'est un gosse quoi si oui
alors tu as compris moment je suis en
train de te dire que daniel a tempéré
elle attend agos quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bah
et que va dire qu'on perd pourquoi tu as
l'intention de le mettre au courant
enfin vous jurer que veux tu que je
fasse on voit l'achète inclus si donc
l'uci oui au sus
tu es folle tu ne peux même pas faire
une chose pareille à cet enfant qui
préfère qu'elle la fasse tout seul
weening et on peut savoir que les
l'auteur mais paraît qu'il ne veut rien
dire
elle ignore peut-être qu'ils auront sans
doute les garçons de la bande
la bande mais oui les amis danny teddy
gilbert ou un autre vidéo et donc je ne
crois pas que jean georges est trop bas
pour maman tu imagines est en train de
faire une enfant quelqu'un de boom
moi et les jeunes gens dont tu parles tu
des jeunes gens refusent amusante si je
les entendais parler quelquefois
lorsqu'ils sont seuls ces jeunes gens
une bande de tissu nick oui je voudrais
que tu les entends tu abordé dans la rue
thiers jusqu'au bout du tunnel jamais
flirter toi quand tu sortais une ou deux
fois j'ai embrassé un garçon alors tu
font des bébés de là puisque tu veux
maintenant c'est la même chose pour fuir
un peu plus poussé voilà tout c'est un
fort c'est un excellent sûr mais c'est 3
qu'est ce que je vais faire madame oui
madame
il faut absolument que je dise quelque
chose à madame compositeur la wii mais
ça m'ennuie faudra pas faire de la peine
à madame vous avez cassé quelque chose
oui mais c'est pas ça c'est plus grave
si vous saviez ma pauvre rien ne peut
plus être grave maintenant mais c'est
vous qui avez touché au papier que sur
mon bureau oui mais ce que je disais
bien en ordre
bon bah oui messieurs je les ai mis en
kilos dans un coin au pilon vous
entendez sa liste combien de fois
faudra-t-il vous dire que je ne veux pas
qu'on fasse le ménage dans mon bureau
mais messieurs y avait plein de pouce si
je m'en fiche je vous devais entrer chez
moi sous aucun prétexte est clair bien
ne sont pas autre chose
je vais laisser un chouchou nattawut
ainsi le siège à fouetter
non monsieur je laisse tirer quoi
oui je n'ai pas fait exprès je fais tout
ça vous avez inspiré ce chèque
oui monsieur j'en avais fait non il
était tout déchirer alors je n'ai acheté
cette affaire je vous interdis de fermer
le chez moi mon absence l'a bien et fait
rouler par hasard inspiré des boutons de
manchette
les bleus aussi monsieur surnoms comme
we n'aime que ça fait si josé mourinho
s'est pas senti
cette maison un nombre incalculable de
coups de pied au derrière j'espère c'est
pas croyable en
daniel qui est ce monsieur daniel je te
perds je demande qu'elle est l'individu
que je vais devoir sortir de la salle de
bain assemien daniel je te prie pour
répondre si le plan n'est pas là mais si
l'un la patrie en que sophie 6,7 à
moulins et la roma bas c'est mauvais
pour tokyo là tu le connais que ce type
là chelsea
activia lunettes que je ne vois sortir
de la salle que partagent une bonne
maman sont là tu peux pas la boucle
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
mais qu'est-ce qui fait dans ma salle de
bain il fait sa toilette allégé at elle
répondu voilà allô allô oui monsieur
chez toi monsieur oui
quittez pas je partiel et la
mademoiselle dominique oui c'est le
téléphone vous êtes n'a pas je vous le
dis c'est téléphone c'est pour moi je
crois j'y vais
allô oui quitte à l'appareil genre ses
voûtes charlie commandés les fout lâche
on ne voit plus le film
non non il n'y a rien de conclu j'ai
fait un bout d'essai vous savez ça ne
veut rien dire mais c'est cela mon
mariage d'hélène vous savez la
canadienne avec un trend de haut
il paraît que je suis tout à fait
personne n'a agi seul et son assassin
c'est une pêche à une peugeot robotique
qui connaît une norton compétition 650
ses chefs mais non par 650 billets 6 à
50 centimètres cube c'est la cylindrée
c'est incroyable a commenté le faire
rire cas si stupide ça tu peux dire que
les vernis n'en verra pas tous les jours
comme sa latence et elle s'est lâchée
double arbre à cames en tête pistons
miss perry et 160 en rond et moi aussi
je te lâcher se manger pas d'eau
il sait combien du faux départ était
pour monter à 100 on s'abaisse sapé
comme je l'entends rien tu meurs elle
m'énerve ça n'aide pas sa faute
téléphone alors 10 h he was i 20 minutes
de mieux pourquoi pendant deux heures
les six bons plans tant le tort de
compter jusqu'à six étaient ceinturés
aline six bombes
tyler est de contrôler deux minutes
hamad a vraiment aucune idée de la
question là et c'est toujours là
mais maintenant j'y connais rien dans
les moteurs bon ça tu peux le dire je
parle et qui sait même pas pourquoi les
arbres à cames et en tête l'arbre à
cames effarant et ça veut conduire
françois tu vas pc spectacle ça égoïste
excusez moi je fais vraiment regarde les
affaires ça sucré mais c'est quand même
fantastique même si elle est
complètement siphonnée
quelqu'un c'est fou ce qu'on est bien
dans cette maison quand ils sont tous
partis a pas un intérieur bourgeois
français moyen oui c'est comme ça chez
toi et oui fatimé pensions les pieds non
non c'est à cause de ton beau père ne
sait pas où elle mange toujours pour
arriver quand ils sont partis aussi
comme ça c'est respirable pro et coûteux
écoute c'est un peu ça vraiment la pluie
s'est plaint ou ça vous gueule d'ange
rentrée coûte
ça avance afin que l'oubli
c'est bien la couronne en somme soit
pourrie que tu puisses te rouler en
boule à proximité d'une source de
chaleur
oh c'est marrant les filles ah oui tout
est toujours tout simple pour elle pas
de souci le sens du confort et en avant
à où les juges tu crois vraiment que
c'est comme ça mais c'est pour ta
conception sais pas répond dit quelque
chose quoi j'ai rien à dire puisque deux
je te dise moi j'ai même pas ce que
c'est qu'un arbre à cannes un cas me me
revois mademoiselle est vexé le dos mais
j'ai rien à dire mais là tu es bien il
jack devient alors bien sûr gainsbourg
de chaleur à proximité
ok ce que tu peux être susceptible mais
pourquoi es-tu susceptible comme ça avec
moi un coup de thulé poids avec les
autres les autres les copains que tu
réponds mais ça sert à rien de parler
m'enfin bon enfin quand on est des êtres
humains ça s'explique des êtres humains
là que qu'est ce que tu veux que je
t'explique tu me dis si oui ou non tu te
trouve bien avec moi ça peut te faire ça
te regarde
j'aime pas dire des trucs reste rien
après mais ça dépend pas toujours
alors l art fois rome et retiendra mais
pourquoi des sentiments parce que j'en
ai à [ __ ] en fin d'après midi si ça ne
va pas ce que j'attendais dit gilbert à
ça je te jure qu'ils vont déguster il va
falloir qu'ils avouent un viendront pas
viendront qua non et pourquoi parce que
je leur ai dit pas vous dire quoi
oui mais qu'est ce qu'ils font mais de
quoi je me mêle quelques scuds prends tu
te fous de moi ou quoi
il reste plus que toi qu'est ce que ça
veut dire que tu trafiques exactement
sera fait que rien du tout j'ai réfléchi
beaucoup de vous seul je n'ai pas voulu
petit ridicule ou au moins que je
molécules - oui non peut-être en train
de dire lequel se gaver ça ma soeur ou
se voudra que vous régulariser la
situation
ça tirait malfrats ont alors tenté un
peu gonflé toi alors non j'ai raison
puis la langue doit fermer les yeux je
dois te faire complaisance on vous dit
ça non mais tulpan dit non alors qu'est
ce que tu penses à l'ambroisie soir là
d'un petit plan c'est à derniers du
doigt par denis oui c'est elle qui doit
dire qui c'est c'est pas bon alors ça se
forme il a ces faux d'alpiq
c'est fuligineux leur était complètement
débile et voit dans le pape en se
tassant 100 pages qu'on me tue sinequa
pas dans la tension vient d'arrêter
n'est faire valoir et mademoiselle
l'ordi tranquillement ou dérangés par
l'écossé pour la peine on se
débrouillera bien sans nous ont tant
fait impensable mais jamais dit ça non
alors alors peut-on savoir l'objet de
vos conversations au tripartite s'est
pas semblables non tu as trouvé ça tout
seul tu nous tiens teddy gilbert n'ont
jamais couché avec ta seule
selon rémy calland do you love me
tonight et chez vous rassemblez ma chère
cela m'attriste c'est pas là et c'est
pas vrai tu crois tu sens again non non
non s'il n'avait pas dit la vérité je
m'en serais aperçu alors peut-on
connaître qu'on à confusion de ces
messieurs
teddy comme d'habitude ils s'en
fichaient pense qu'à lui mais gilbert il
est embêté vachement mais pourquoi il
aime bien d'amis et au passage on
l'aperçoit vient de me prouver
tu dis désigné si c'est pas lui mais ils
aiment dany vraiment eu c'est bon c'est
possible après tout c'est ce qui m'a dit
ah non mais vas-y et bien éventuellement
je crois qu'il se marierait avec
quelques oies we had dans l'état où
elles se trouvent il s'en être qu'au
père oui bon là
alors tu vois ça c'est de la mise à dix
trouvent pas ça normal non par les
doubles pas les nouvelles et nova et
nous sommes enfin quoi elle pourra
épouser mcv comme ma soeur par son cas
alors vouloir adapter la coupe et des
copains leur statut permet aux ti
concordia tout moi match comme ça un
pensum tu fais l'été les filles charmant
monsieur s'est levé du bon pied
mercer je suppose qu'ils d'amis
non pourquoi natation la voiture
fugitive ainsi fugitif oui je sais les
fameuses antennes féminines c'est comme
senti une sorte de pressentiment et tu
as alors entre eux carrément dans le vif
du sujet tétouan délicieux c'est comme
ça qu'on parle à cette petite femme
c'est beau le mariage fois par le plus
tôt de toi tu crois pas deux mois mais
enfin de vous deux si tu préfères je
vois oui alors au mont fuji pour les
revues quoi tu conscient moi c'était
fini commence à m'énerver sérieusement
mais moi ça va je fais ce que je peux
pour la sortie du pétrole suit tout ce
que je peux et mademoiselle prend désir
condescendant ben non c'est l'ironie je
me suis pour qu'on sache de quel pétrin
victime tirait au dessus de 6 mois et
coûte françois j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya un malentendu on va s'amuser plutôt
je ne t'ai jamais demandé de s'occuper
de ce type en oui elle est au courant
bon donc je te disais que je ne paie
jamais demandé puis je sais que je
savoure parce que ça me regarde tu es ma
soeur nom d allah kwaï alors tu trouve
anormal que je te laisse te débrouiller
quand il fallait apprendre quelle
connerie de faire des villes auront que
tu dois t'en veux tu pense à moi j'ai
plus 15 ans le pétrin dont il parle je
me trouve très bien et j'ai l'intention
d'y rester
si tu n'y vois pas d'inconvénient quoi
parfaitement c'est mon droit non notre
plus de ça alors monsieur réjouit les
personnes à nom de ce marbre homophobe
ou de saluer le cube n'importe quoi
maintenant et pas n'importe quoi
je sais très bien ce que je fais ce que
je veux et je peux te dire que je suis
ravi de ce qui m'arrive bien tant en
chanter c'est sensationnel mais vous
tout au tout
invaincus en temps non mais tendance à
croire qu'elle est a peur on voit que je
suis tombé sur la tête
et bien non je ne suis pas tombé sur la
tête je tends agace c'est merveilleux tu
ne peux pas comprendre ça toi évidemment
on si je suis ici je suis très capable
de comprendre ce que tu peux ressentir
faf a tout de même mis dans un monde
civilisé certaines réalités basse h -
fous et si tu veux parler des l'opinion
des gens mais non mais non enfin je dis
simplement autonome et course on assiste
cette histoire la principale intéressée
c'est moi et personne d'autre et le père
non pas le père s'occupe pas de ça je te
quitte à laisser tomber un écoute
françois n'insiste pas je te dirais bien
personne ne sera jamais j'avais quand
même dans une esclave françois n'assiste
pas qu'on me l'enlève son dos un goût
bien lorsque moi parce que j'aime le
foot quand en face des points méritant
vous savez pas eh bien il faudra nous
faire réviser le carburateur
[Applaudissements]
ce ne sera pas pour bacchus et averti
que ça s'est passé deux mois - soit la
cua et retour ça laisse à faro oui il
est content bien évidemment moi si on
avait dit il ya six mois
cette année la nouvelle maman quelque
chose qui m'arrive je vous laisse au
revoir madame voir mademoiselle
sinon qu'est ce qui t'arrive mon chéri
deux films en vo non je ne sais pas moi
voyons en dix mois
je vais avoir un petit bébé
non je sais pas possible et assez soit
un cran tu passe arrière grand mère
entendue
tu sais il n'y a presque personne au
courant juste françois toi c'est tout
mais comment vas-tu l'appeler au sol
chez pas sérieusement réfléchi qu'est ce
que tu en penses toi tu devrait
l'appeler germain
charmant mari comme temps pour 30 et tu
trouves pas que c'est un peu vieux pour
un bébé ça me ferait tellement plaisir
bon tiens je te fais une proposition on
coupe la poire en deux on l'appelle du
mit
jimmy est oui mais si c'est une fille
aussi hors de question j'ai commandé un
garçon on se fait pas tout non ce que je
suis content en tout 5 août
je lui tricoter des petites choses c'est
loïc sorte de tube apprendra aussi bien
servir et bien c'est dit moi et me le
père oui enfin que tu vas te marier ce
c'est une autre question
tu comprends il n'est pas libre c'est un
homme marino non c'est pas ça je peux
pas expliquer le grand mère ça ne fait
rien mon chéri ça neuf dernières ben
salah ponapin 86
la virada n'y a pas grand chose qui
compte dans la vie tu sais la santé oui
un joli bébé aussi mêlés aux grands
meurs tu veux que ce disque usine crunch
t'adore et voici ce sont plutôt des
parements comme inquiète
qu'est ce que veut dire cabine au moment
du fait d une fois que je vais embrasser
un garçon à la feuille s'épanouir depuis
je dis plus rien aubry a raison d'abord
il comprend le rapport sont tellement
vieux jeu
[Applaudissements]
et là encore il ya tout à leur papa oui
qu'est-ce que tu ferais si on me disait
qu'une de ses filles à tarragone
quoi je te pose une question séance et
répond facilement je l'écouterai dehors
vachement instructif bon c'est fou ce
que je peux apprendre en ce moment sur
la mortalité des adultes
bah oui décidément c'est bien vrai après
tout mais guère les parents d vous avez
entendu notre fille alice nous devrions
considérer comme parfaitement normal que
nos filles ça fasse faire des enfants à
droite et à gauche on crée auger pas
dire à droite est un condensé tu le
pensait probablement des diffusions ne
vous inquiétez pas ma famille ce sont là
les infos quotidien d'une puberté
tardive et ça ce sont les signes avant
coureurs d'une sénilité précoce
darif une apparente adam ya monsieur
georges qu'elle a il voudrait qu aux
mêmes mais elles dernier georges vas tu
peux pas le faire exprès je ne comprends
pas même page à renens qu'est ce que tu
lui reproches il
son style et henry 2 ce qu'il n'ya que
don juan à temps puis nous avons gagné
ne veut pas le voir mais je recevoir ma
george l'avocat daniel oui c'est pas du
bien aussi ça alors du coup je me mal
juppé assez grands pour savoir ce que ge
a fait un peu tache et peut-on savoir ce
qu à ma place leur est une grande
personne comme toi comme répandre sur un
but de jouer à la maman
mais pas facile parce qu'avoir un petit
peu grâce à un essai en titrant bien qu
parfaitement je me rends compte de nova
est amusé puisque tu me tiens
la nuit s'est parfaitement t'amuser je
suppose que tu ne vas pas te marier
ce serait indigne de toit au sein de
mariée c'est pas possible c'est épouser
il ne risque pas pourquoi on voit des
histoires pour toi ça pour personne
d'ailleurs
mais qu'est ce que tu racontes tu ne
t'occupes pas de ça c'est tout ce que je
te demande on s'arrangera très bien tous
les deux et lui sera très content qui
lui ne me pose pas de questions je peux
pas te répondre
mais si tu savais comme je suis de rohff
complètement siphonnée
bonjour d'amérique
comment allez-vous georges en créant
seraient entrés
mon petit georges je suis bien
malheureuse si vous saviez mais qu'est
ce qui se passe madame jamais je ne
pourrai georges votre petit danny il lui
est arrivé quelques jours afin
d'annoncer pis vous m'entendez pire elle
a fait des bêtises d'affreuses bêtise
près de l'épouvantable bêtise vous
comprenez vous ne comprenez pas j'en
étais sûr vous pouvez pas comprendre ces
choses là mais il faut changer le fond
je dois vous dire je vais vous faire du
mal mon petit votre petite dame elle
attend un bébé
maman elle attend un bébé
mais madame c'est pas possible
les charges c'est vrai c'est
épouvantable c'était pouvant date mais
madame c'est pas possible
mes charges celles habilitées
madame je crois que vous vous trompez
j'ai un jeu brouillon non madame non
cela n'est pas possible enfin daniel n'a
pas pu faire ça non pareil non je la
connais bien moi vous savez et moi je
peux vous dire cela
daniel est incapable d'une vilaine
action non non non ce que je crois c'est
que voilà voilà
je pense qu'il y à une machination
machine un site
oui madame mais georges pourquoi fais tu
vois c'est daniel qui vous a dit ce que
vous venez de me dit non vous voyez bien
ça commence
non madame non non il se passe quelque
chose que nous ignorons non je ne sais
pas quoi
enfin non pas cette histoire au sujet de
dai young mais c'est une pure
fabrication mais je sais une chose très
grave
oui madame mais quand même c'est
possible non ce qui est impossible
comprenez impossible c'est que daniel
ait fait ça c'est emilie qui veulent
être
ah mais pourquoi voulez vous que les
enfants enfin je n'en sais rien madame
mais c'est un fait ça a été inventé
toutes pièces ou c'est un monstre
un mot enfin daniel est incapable de
manse je vous dis entendu que les
damiers lieu où vous n'en savez vous
madame à fuir devant ses responsabilités
madden georges
je ne veux pas qu'on puisse la charge
vous défendez daniel vous êtes un garçon
épatant mais pas moi moi george bush
agissent c'est mon devoir
mais qu'est ce que vous allez faire
je ne sais pas comment faire quelque
chose mais quoi je ne sais pas mais
l'essentiel c'est que je sois là vous
comprenez que daniel puisse prendre ma
mordre votre oeuvre
oui je ne peux pas lui en parler
beaucoup de tact dans une chose comme
celle là mais je serai là et elle le
sentira enfin c'est pas possible pas
possible pas d'animer charge voyant un
petit mois moi je ne crois pas un mot de
tout cela au saut du lit des histoires
je n'aurais jamais dû lui dire une chose
pareille dans années voilà ouija madame
je dois vous dire que je suis
profondément choqué par le fait que vous
puissiez accorder un crédit quelconque à
des médisances dont je trouve moi
qu'elle relève de la plupart diffamation
[Applaudissements]
madame madame bwin
c'est au sujet de ce que je voulais dire
à madame est bien dit le oui madame a
toujours été très bonne pour moi alors
allons parler
eh bien vous savez c'est à propos de la
jeune fille
celle qui était là ce matin il a même
avec daniel comment s'appelle déjà
pinkie finkie oui c'est ça bon alors
bien eh bien je veux dire à madame tube
il faut absolument que madame sache
cette demoiselle ce n'est pas un ami il
mesdemoiselles damien elle la connaît
même pas qu'est ce que vous racontez
non madame c'est demoiselle n'est pas un
ami de mademoiselle daniel c'est une âme
il monsieur de monsieur françois non
madame de monsieur
mais vous perdez les sourires la nuit
madame ce matin genève où elle a bien vu
elle que je l'avais vue à calais plus m
je les ai vus qui sortait de la chance
de monsieur en faisant bien attention
pour la voyais pas et après elle a voulu
aller dans la salle de bains mais la
pente était fermé alors elle s'est de
plus quoi faire
il m'a dame est arrivée jusqu'aux mal à
s'emballer et madame bon je vais bien vu
elle a cru que c'était le film moselle
daniel la chambre de monsieur ce matin
oui madame
c'est comme je vous le dis et dans le
pyjama de monsieur qu'est ce que vous
dites oui madame rien qu la veste
le sheikh ali c'est aussi la première
est chez elle
[Applaudissements]
le moment vous êtes là on pourrait jouer
dire un mot je vous prie non mais qu'est
ce que j'apprends vous recevez ici un
monsieur est tout du jour et de la nuit
vous ne voulez pas me répondre
alors vous voulez que j'ajoute fois ces
rumeurs stupides vous sert andré des
rumeurs stupides
j'ai pas droit une infection par rapport
personnes voient refuser l'affection
vous n'êtes pas heureuse ici enfin les
enfants ne sont pas gentils avec vous
alors qu'est ce qui ne va pas on met
tout ça très bien vrai ça c'est une
grand mère qui est ce monsieur
cet hallali un ami il ya longtemps que
vous le connaissez non pas très c'est un
ami de madame la scène vous l'avez vous
rencontrée sur un banc oui au square il
y à tous les jours à midi
deuxième en juin je comprends alors vous
avez des connaissances
non mais pourquoi diable le recevez vous
en cachette parce que ça ne serait pas
convenable que les gens sans le voir aux
covenants bon vous avez tout de même le
droit de recevoir et c'est qu'ils
voulaient les enfants passent mais c'est
bien qu'ils se moquent
mais pourquoi mais pour eux je suis une
vieille dame très très vite
il pense pas que cela allait me on peut
avoir des amis à tout âge n'est pas un
ami
elle me va avec que voulez vous dire
vous ne pensez pas que les enfants
supposerait une seconde
les enfants de cette visite
ces deux vies
ben non monsieur monsieur a fait cet ami
il restera la maison wigno le quai leur
arrive-t-il le soir après dîner vous ne
voulez pas dire qu'ils partent toutes
les deux dans votre chambre et va bien
si ma mère je sais bien qu'à votre
enfant ne doit pas beaucoup faire la
causette avec un ami comme ça de dix
heures du soir à sept heures du matin
ce n'est pas très raisonnable mais nous
ne faisons pas la cause est tout le
temps
alors là j'avoue que je ne comprends pas
mais si voyons haderer souvent il ne
porte une petite kicker et puis avant
juillet à de cuisine sur mon réchaud
mais on adore la soupe au lait
alors nous causent ans quand il a fini
de dîner au moi vous savez je ne mange
pas grand chose nous buvons la petite iq
heures et on joue à la belote au bout
d'un moment il fait les éclairages on
écoute le peuple
il fait des éclairages
bah oui il met des foulards sur les
lampes
l'autre jour yann acquis à rustines ça
sentait mauvais
heureusement il avait vite fait de
sauter du lit leiter
[Applaudissements]
ces machines couple coule dans votre lit
non mais vous alors sa défense
quelquefois sur le foot
ou bien j'ai installé mon vieux transat
leur grand-mère que quel âge à ce
monsieur il dit qu'il ya 71
mais comme il est très coquet moi je
crois qu'il a au moins dans les 72 c'est
insensé
je ne sais pas j'avoue je suis stupéfait
et pas vous voyez j'avais réseau pour
les enfants les enfants
mais si mais si ce serait un très
mauvais exemple vous vous demanderez
très mauvais non mais vous qu'en mer
vous vous n'avez pas idée que ceux de ce
n'est deux points en fin de cette
aventure
évidemment ça me dit que c'est pas très
bien oui je devrais me parler à monsieur
pury et puis vous savez je ne dis rien
c'est nous les soirées à mon âge
bonneteau repent et n'ont jamais dit que
de la recevoir toute la nuit dans votre
chambre à monsieur que vous ne
connaissez pas mais elle connaît très
bien maintenant
montmagny est vrai que garceau ya plus d
habitude
c'est bien ce que c'est qu'anthony tous
tél le célibataire non c'est un deuil
mais c'est comme si c'était un vieux
garçon il est neuf depuis si longtemps
mais je ne trouvais rien à répondre
c'est insensé
vous vous livrer gratuitement
comment ça lui coûte même très jeune je
me suis vous donne de l'argent aux mais
on joue à la belote à son front du coin
chaffraix de coin c'est que je prie
[Applaudissements]
avant hier je lui ai pris 81 me faut
quelques problèmes les franges de la
catalyse gallimard on ne sait pas le
faire pour tenir tenue ce mois ci je me
suis à 430 2700 francs de biens
430 2700 francs de gains et bien votre
maman
vous gagnez tout le temps ça il
suffirait
mais c'est du vol j'avais en vrai il n'a
pas de famille comme moi et puis mais
qui voulez vous qu'ils sachent
est ce que vous vous rendez compte oui
vous croyez que je ne devrais pas faire
ça alors vous ne vous rendez pas compte
mais c'est très mal ce que vous faites
vous serez bien content quand je serai
mort de trouver deux stars je vous savez
ça fait plus de trois millions puis diot
vous lui avez pris 3 millions mais vous
êtes et épandre et il en a d'autres mais
petit à petit je gagne normalement ça ne
peut pas continuer comme ça c'est
impossible
ça vous allait rembourser ce monsieur je
me suis donné assez mal pour les pauvres
je me demande si je deviens fou si je
rêve ou quoi
est ce que vous réalisez ce que vous
faites n'est pas fait moins bien sur mon
avenir
et ouais mais vous mais tout cet argent
j'ai acheté valeur en bourse
boursica là tu me faisais reste
intéressant j'ai guerriau thing to les
royal dutch en vo ça montrait bien au
capital augmente et qui vous conseillent
et ben oui comment et ben si c'est lui
c'est ce monsieur voulu prenez son
argent et vous conseille pour le
placenta grand mère je tire mon chapeau
j'ai déjà rencontré pas mal baissé enfin
de gens malades il ne poussait pas le
cynisme là si vous ne savez pas tout le
trajet sur un thibaut des conseils
j'avais un peu perdu
eh ben il m'a dit de venir s'ajouter
comme ça vous allez m'écouter si vous
refusez de rembourser ce monsieur c'est
moi qu'il fait et je vous interdit de le
revoir par la suite
bon et bien lorsqu'on irez vous en avez
rêvé où ça a fini à venise parfaitement
et avec lui vous des réseaux n'est pas
du tout vrai mais vous savez je ne
connais pas encore l'italie donc ce que
pense à moi c'est quelque chose
d'insensé de les besoins criants près
d'une école dans cet état il n'y a pas
de quoi fouetter un chat à vous trouver
d'ailleurs vous savez je crois qu'il
s'est aperçu que je pose ma vie
seulement voilà il ne sait pas comment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelle génération d'un montant
parfaitement de montants qu'il va vous
voyez comme les copains pas du tout nous
a plu un minimum de respect pour nos
aînés nous les respectons là tu appelle
ça du respect vous n'en fait qu'à votre
tête vous imaginez que nous sommes de
vieux croûtons vous vous lancer tête
baissée dans les pierres un
empoisonnement et tout ça pourquoi parce
que vous ne voulez pas recevoir de
conseils me tue c'est l'expérience des
autres que les taux affichent d'idiot
[Applaudissements]
l'expérience en manque et tout est
relancé sa femme née loin très loin et
ses photos enfin j'ai plus 15 ans y en a
20 c'est énorme en effet le commencement
de la fin la vieillesse cris et tu
trouves que maintenant c'est un âge pour
se marier quand on est encore chez ses
parents comptent pas la moindre
situation même pas quoi je travaillerai
tu travailleras toi pas possible on veut
bien sûr
et quoi s'il te plaît tant voyant de
formation intellectuelle que des styles
sans doute aux plus hauts postes de
l'administration
un orchestre alors que c'est parfait mon
fils va abandonner sa médecine et
devenir musicien et tout ça pour quoi
pour épouser un nourrisson de 18 points
tant qu'il reste alors dans mon
appartement en attendant impatiemment
que je passe ma fuite ben écoute un
orchestre 1 je suppose que tu vas venir
répéter ici
enfin je peux t'aider de temps en temps
on line quoi entre les répétitions jeu
je voulais te dire que je parle
sérieusement à projets c'est ce qui
m'inquiète
peut-on savoir pourquoi actuelle décider
si soudainement d'épouser cette jeune
personne petits voire jusqu'à présent
franchement ils n'ont pas perçu elle non
plus d'ailleurs mais quand on se voit
quoi tu comprends ça marche pas on est
obligé de se téléphoner
alors on a décidé de se marier quoi
voilà et voilà comment on fait la plus
belle année de sa vie non quid papa il
soit chic dramatise pas espèces dames et
chez nous monsieur veut vivre sa vie il
va se marier à mes fans et bien entendu
il va installer sa dulcinée ici et faire
semblant de le gagner sa vie dans
l'écart pendant ce temps la dulcinée qui
se morfond à la maison qui se bagarre
avec ta mère tu es ce un pays si dans
six mois la vie ne sera plus tenable a
battu celle actuellement ce n'est pas
une raison pour ajouter le timbre est
plus à l'établissement
dans l'ailé soit chic fait quelque chose
pour moi tu ne vois pas plus aux
attentes aidé mon vieux j'essaie de
t'empêcher de faire une énorme bêtise
tiens si tu voulais m'écouter au lieu de
beauty stupidement ouais je te parie à
déjeuner à la tour d'argent que dans
cinq ans c'est toi qui me remercieras
non mais je t'assure je suis sûr de moi
alors j'ai trés mieux de vous êtes en ce
grand amour de l'an passé c'est comme ça
brusquement non enfin c'est bien qu'on
se marie maintenant sinon tu fais des
blagues au nom sympa du tout tu y es tu
toi sur ce motif oppose à tout le monde
quoi est ce qu'on pourra faire vivre
comme ça de gauche à droite c'est pas
humain non non non c'est quand même la
première possibilité quand on veut
changer un fouet on arrête dans la vie
certaines réalités rue morel s'était
parfois la poularde suprême et moi la
loi d'allah suprême tu comprends moi je
m'en fous enfin la prendre écoute moi
que je ne suis pas encore assez cynique
pour ne pas comprendre ton point de vue
mais je n'ai pas l'intention de laisser
hypothéquer l'avenir comme ça bêtement
sur une simple passade
tout ce que je peux faire je te fais une
proposition
j'écoute facile toi tu me dis que cette
costa plus son père qu'elle est libre
comme l'air probablement alors profité
du week-end pour représenter l'année
allaient vite là la donne dans une
tension étant bien entendu que tu ne
laisses un pas sur les mois pour avec un
impérieux on a envie que tu te conduira
avec elle
en gentleman est naturellement sous
réserve que ta mère soit d'accord elle
le sera j'en ai sur wii et se sont
rencontrés ici l'autre matin il paraît
qu'elles ont tout de suite sympathisé
si où elles ont dû parler chiffons elle
est si gentille que ça au boîtier en
garde
voilà tout chez elle qu'elle ressemble
leslie caron non à la tante germaine
nature charrie papa est là le même
sourire un peu triste mais ce garçon qui
la tient par la taille de la pièce
bassa'a que c'est un copain ça bravo tu
n'es pas chez elles ou tout au moins on
pense qu'imad est littéralement folle de
moi c'est pas passé aussi maladie at-on
boury couleurs le reconnaître et d'une
délicate et en quad et l'extraordinaire
bien je te signale cependant que
l'original où ils se trouvent derrière
toi mais l entente et la toile non on va
la salle quand on parle du loup et voilà
c'est elle
je vois bonjour monsieur je me posais
correspond comme ça dit quelque chose
voilà non ne vous inquiétez à meloisey
bons offices et c'est de vous mettre en
confiance ce soir oui parfaitement
belle tir idéale
tu m'intimides peut-être moins je suis
pas si l'enfant soit tu ne peux pas être
gentil est allé me chercher la voiture
maintenant tu peux bien me rendre ce
service
non mais là où ça que j'ai compris
il est plein de tact oui tu es bien sûr
que les actus sont chargés
signé jumanji set je vous prie
maintenant c'est mieux rester debout et
bien si vous permettez je vais m'asseoir
pour soi m'a beaucoup parlé vous et si
j'ai bien compris ce qu'il m'a dit il a
décidé de vous épousez non non c'est moi
qui ai pris cette décision à bon dieu
nous a fait deux mois que je prépare mon
cou oui vous avez raison d'agir ainsi
oh oui ça va l'équilibré l'équilibré oui
vous comprenez en ce moment en france où
était stable hésitant les cherche sa
voie
alors j'ai décidé de me remettre en
selle et vous pensez que le mariage aux
évidemment à vous savez françois il est
très bien au fond non oui mais vous
croyez qu'il saura vous rendre heureuse
la question n'est pas là non
non vous comprenez je veux l'aider
je veux qu'il réussisse je sais qu'il
peut seulement il lui manque un but
vous comprenez abus il faut un foyer au
nom ici ce n'est pas rien c'est le vôtre
bah oui j'avais pas pensé
et vous allez avoir des enfants quatre
classes
pourquoi cap à cause des adaptations des
importations a failli ça devient
intéressant et vous saurez les élever ok
pourquoi pas c'est difficile aujourd'hui
d'être parents oh mais faut être très
ferme au départ ressenti ça enfin nous
verrons mais c'est tout vu si on
s'entend bien avec françois et on
s'entendra bien les gars ça faudra
qu'elles marchent droit
vous n'êtes pas essayer de vous marier
restés bloqués qu'aujourd'hui tous les
jeunes étaient pressés vous n'avez pas
mourir demain vous savez monsieur il ya
une chose que vous ne comprenez pas là
je vous savez ça ne veut rien dire c'est
la maturité qui cote
et nous nous avons déjà besoin de
responsabilité
oui tout ça c'est très joli mais vous
pouvez arrêter quand même de vous donner
mon avis et bien sûr voyons longer
apathiques les jeunes avec une curieuse
manière de prendre leurs responsabilités
en fait ils comptent surtout sur les
parents allons-y marions-nous pâte à
ferrals appartement mon manga bras des
gosses non mes hanches et genoux est une
d'abord vous pouvez tromper
nous ne sommes pas tous comme cela non
vous savez combien je gagne non des 100
me normal qu'est ce que vous faites
j'essaie chimiste dans une grosse boîte
juristes dans deux ans je serai diplômés
à je travaille actuellement sur les
primaires vous connaissez je suis
industriel mais serré oui mais j'ai
souvent remarqué que les hommes
d'affaires ne connaissent pas grand
chose aux questions techniques bien moi
je sais très bien ce que c'est que la
polymérisation
mais c'est tout à votre honneur
parfait parfait je vois qu'il existe
encore des liens communs entre les
générations et je vous laisse je suis
enchanté d'avoir votre connaissance moi
aussi on doit aussi voir la moselle vous
êtes beaucoup plus sérieux que je ne le
croyais merci
elle étend d'antalya plutôt fois elle
est pas mal du tout
elle est pas mal du tout cette gosse a
vu ses jambes à ans j'ai pondu ces gens
c'est pas ça dont je parle du plomb dans
la tête ce n'est pas n'importe qui n'ont
battu et ça ne m'étonnerait pas que quoi
qu'elle te met dans sa poche mais comme
c'est andres ça ça c'est pas encore fait
à l'eau qui tombe à ça non je vois petit
c'est certainement une erreur connais
toi y'a pas de dorit ici les ardennes
série bones ou même en face à non alors
ça ça change tout c'est merveilleux
c'est merveilleux ça j'avoue que deux
mini qui en train d'interpréter le rôle
de maria chape de l'air là ça vaudra le
déplacement
alors comme ça vous dire quelques mots
sur de ricard bel et bien vous savez moi
je suis le frère
oui oui on atteint vite mon nom à
l'atomic moala défendent un mur du point
de vue clinique elle présente certains
troubles psychiques qui la rendent dans
l'abord difficile et qui se concrétise
pourrions-nous dire sous la forme d'une
instabilité total et d'une
insatisfaction permanente
c'est une cyclique
en tant que médecin non non moi je fais
mes études de médecine
je pense qu'une séance ou d'électrochoc
lui ferait le plus grand bien mais ses
passes ou quoi d'autre que je vois pas
vraiment vraiment je vois qu on
attendait attendait doit voir voilà une
bonne quarantaine d'années elle est
élevée au couvent des oiseaux
ce qui lui a laissé une empreinte quasi
indélébile
ils ont parfait d'oiseau aux ailes juin
l'intelligence de loi la simplicité du
pont
vous voyez qui allait marquer si elle
est bonne comédienne au ca non non non
mais enfin on a quand même que vous la
voyez à ses meilleures scènes c'est papa
a pas de moi de l'argent tous les hommes
sont des non pas tout ça n'a pas
tellement le rapport avec moi j'achète
de l'america font du profit
salo moi que tu es bien donné mon nom
personnel a jamais dit que j'allais vous
tuer c'est plus négatif ici bas je te la
négation même qu'est ce que je te fais
moi que c'est très bien vient le
chercher à ridiculiser juste au moment
où j'ai ma chance aurais tu vas faire
pleurer je crois portez-vous bah oui je
sais je finirai sur l'échafaud tu
m'avais troisième ours a tué habitait
dans les histoires d'abus de confiance
de la crâne aux mines ou pickpockets
voilà une histoire de chantage peut-être
non je t en prie ne voit pas les
drapeaux yéménites de pater moi non mais
écoutez moi ça ça te piquer ben ça c'est
trop drôle alors oui j'aurais comme ça
tient à vous faire la morale dit tu veux
junnila père pourquoi on consomme 808
données par mois
histoire de se décontracter l'épiderme
je vous apprenez à l'acte et voyous
craquer vous allez vous termes de
sondages
oui vous vous croyez vous nous prenez
cette maison pourquoi je vous demande
pourquoi je rencontre bureau quand même
santander crever parfois entretenir
bangle limaces mais qu'est ce que je
trouve celui là prêts à tous les
sacrifices mais bien pour se passer la
corde au cou celle-là en extase à l'idée
de montrer son derrière à 20 millions de
personnes
la mère malade qui me fait la tête la
grand mère
oui
il a beau bijou de la guitare celle là
qui se tiennent un peu tranquille n'a
pas encore jeté ton scooter sur un vieil
or n'ont pas de projets grandioses
tu ne vas pas te faire teindre les
cheveux modifier le nez à tous des soins
à temps les mieux que toi tu es bien
certaine que tu n'as rien annoncé chez
moi tout quantifier en vitesse
il croit que ja pas ils veulent avoir
des nouvelles tout va bien le jcj jamais
j'apprends petit excitante et tenues de
quoi toutefois cadors ne te donnerai pas
s'exprimer c'est à devenir démentes
mais joint et je vous ai du sang fois
que je ne voulais pas compliqué pas
- ah c'est vous bon voilà ce pack vous
apprends libre et je ne fais rien mon
vieux téléphoné à bertin cette affaire
avec lui mais non mais non ça n'a pas
d'importance
faites ce que je vous dis ne discutait
pas c'est simple et certains donnez lui
une condition c'est ça qui est humain
appelez moi oui je suis chez moi enfin
presque
si l'on peut dire
et vous qu'est ce que vous avez à me
regarder comme ça qu'est ce que vous
avez fait tout ce que vous voudrez ici
ou ailleurs
et laissez-moi pompiers ont ils fait
encore ils n'ont rien ça c'est vous
rendrez vous le savez bien moi qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire vous osez
me demandez vous osez l'ont gardé en
saas et me demander ce que j'ai alors
qu'ici monde dans cette maison nous
avons été tellement heureux ensemble
au début c'est très laid cetrel
jamais cru capable d'une chose pareille
jalouse est complètement folle qu'est ce
que vous racontez
je ne serai pas de bruit vous aurez
toute la nuit on attend dé moi un cachet
qu'elle mois 12,7 pardon quoi j'ai pardo
bailly le robinet pour robin a dû
comprendre à pain
il ya des led dans la vie tu penses que
je comprends ta aussi j'ai de
l'expérience qui s'est jetée expérience
mon dieu c'est vraiment petit françois
matudi eux seuls non non non il a bien
fait c'est pourtant bien seulement il
n'a pas voulu me dire qu'ils s'étaient
de six mois qui a été méchant
dernière j'ai compris qu'il moi en quoi
cette avance rage d'un coup jure je moi
qui n'en parle à personne je te le jure
c'est georges et oui georges
dartiguenave que veux tu le printemps le
bois de boulogne
le bruit des vagues oui nouveau dion sur
le lac
mon dieu ma fille tu que l'on tue ses
charges à contre-jour gagneur on choisit
pas toujours
d'ailleurs j'ai résisté mais c'est que
ce que tu sais un homme dans ces moments
là mais acculé qui l'équipe au petit lot
de très gentil il m'a dit qu'il ne
fallait pas me défendre que j'avais jo
lisieux que je ne devrais pas toujours
où on vieillit vite tu sais maman
il faut profiter de sa jeunesse c'est
l'été de la vie tu comprends ça aussi
n'avait dit que ça sera pas marché tu
penses j'en ai vu d'autres
mais voilà il assume parler tu es ma
princesse aux cheveux de la via après
deux mois nous allons faire un beau
voyage
nous allons aux as it heures
oui alors tu comprends je me suis
laissée endormir et toc
lacoste et dans mille remarque que j'ai
bien senti le danger
mais si tu m'appelles septembre c'est
mieux il a enjambé le petit banc il m'a
prise par la main et il m'a dit venez ma
princesse
nous sommes arrivés ici c'est cythère
l'effet de l'amour sont là comment les
faits f et es tu comprends l1 quand
l'amour et la jeunesse venait et moi
crétine j'ai débarqué il à fès et lui
alors après il m'a entraîné vers lui
sont impuissants
il s'est assis moi aussi il s'est
allongé moi aussi et là où tu es toi tu
es là brusquement il est devenu nerveux
il m'a dit tu occupes pas de ça et
violent allez viens viens viens on va
partir de là je ne sais plus qui s'est
passé mais je me suis dit allez tant pis
ni vu ni connu je saute
ce qui est déplorable c'est que j'ai
sauté pour petits budgets
et oui ce sont des choses qui arrivent
michaud
tu dis maman c'est fichu pour moi
maintenant je suis la honte de la
famille
oui au noirmont
tu sais je ne sais plus et épouvantable
remarque dans un sens c'est pas si mal
tu comprends je me suis en quelque sorte
accrue
et oui c'est une autre vie qui commence
pour moi maintenant je suis une femme
une femme donc on fait plus c'est
vraiment super ce pas si mal
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est un monstre
mais sait-on
allo litres est moins de 6 e 67
je voudrais pas remis à monsieur georges
dartiguenave s'il vous plaît n'est pas
là et oui t-il à la pêche à la pop
dans un moment pareil andré georges et à
la pêche
ah qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ça me
déchire
andré notre fille a fait des bêtises
elle a accordé une interview à playboy
mise à niveau bas danila quel genre de
bêtises la plus grave qui affecte charge
justement l'assureur oui ce garçon
n'était pas du tout ce que nous croyons
andré c'était insupportable à la forme
suit borna il a profité d'un instant de
faiblesse de dany est un peu blessé bois
debout là une bride eva bleu clair de
lune classique et non jaune
c'est daniel qui vous en raconter ça oui
mais vous l'avez cru comment non je vous
demande si vous l'avez cru faudrait être
fou
mon dieu ma pauvre ami que vous êtes
naïve on pouvait avoir la décence de me
dire je vous prie oui mais veste de
pyjama
eh bien on est elle passée elle est
passée ici monsieur hier matin à 11
heures
savait capable de plaisanterie de
mauvais goût mais manqué de tact ce
point c'est un peu fort
ce n'est pas vous par hasard quirion
emprunter ma veste de pyjama
non et bien si vous avez dans cette
maison autant d'autorité qu'on me laisse
entendre
éclaircissez ce mystère je vous prie il
paraît que ma veste circulent
[Applaudissements]
mon mari c'est très bien mais cette
veste
ah oui je suis entouré en ce moment un
peu d'hypocrisie et de mauvaise foi
ah oui oui
si vous allez à la pêche a mis au bois
de boulogne peut-être au bois il y à un
lac ossa habite mais oui en effet des
bateaux une hymne georges je suis
épouvantablement déçu maintenez-vous
change et n'ajouter par le fiel de
l'hypocrisie et la lâcheté de votre
geste d'anima tout tout tout la
princesse aux cheveux de la l'accostage
un super doux même les buissons à celle
c7 agnel qui vous a raconté tout cela
oui
genre je recommande vivement de chance
pas
mais nulle madame n'est à l'abri d'un
instant de faiblesse mais seriez un
passionné hélas madame line up vous
n'êtes pas un passionné vous avait tout
prémédité
elle me dit solidement ce n'est pas par
hasard je suppose que vous avez
d'accoster dans cette île en réalité
vous l'avait attiré dans un guet-apens
non mode a gelé prise par la main et je
lui ai dit venez daniel nous sommes
jeunes
il fait beau allons nous étendre sur la
plage bras oui madame n'a pas plein bois
de boulogne
oui c'est ce qu'elle va faire marquer
mais je lui ai dit daniel tous les lieux
sont des plages où deux êtres épris
peuvent s'étendre et s'aimer vous avez
dit si oui madame que c'est
madame je fais les asperges pour ce soir
on écoute et arlene ne vais pas
importuner en ce moment oui je connais
ça fait après tout et qui prendra t as
rome je vous en prie moi je préfère
comme elle me dit alors celle des
asperges et les signes d'accord chacun
ses responsabilités
mais par moments avec odieuse
nous n'étions mougins nous parlions de
la plage
madame g plus d'huile écouter à même de
battre la mesure oublier une
conversation grave important contre
monsieur georges alors s'il n'ya pas où
il allait en chercher
il ya peu d'initiatives enfin bien
madame alors qu'est ce que vous attendez
de l'argentine vous pensez pas au
programme en faire cadeau vais tout
d'abord en avant mais prenez bien dans
mon sac
au revoir l'homme au revoir madame
ma place madame je vais me retirer ou ne
vous dit rien du souper ou madame en
l'occurrence c'est moi qui décide
j'ai l'habitude de prendre des
responsabilités
non je ne suis pas celui que vous croyez
je ne suis pas cette soudure à 10h à sa
tirelire lui qu'est ce qu'il faut
entendre
oh là là bas nous demain tanzanie
descend tout de suite
écoute famille à cause de toi toute la
maison et dans le cirage écoute du
boîtier le père une charge sur un cahier
permettre ça écoute madani je pèse mes
mots tu ne sortiras pas vivante de cette
maison avant de la boire avant de
m'avoir tout raconter à ce sujet mais
c'est un gestapo ici parfaitement
il est allé s'imposer seconde de répit
pour la réduire si toute cette histoire
toutefois pas une seconde mais qu'est ce
que tu ferais si je te le disais on va
agir et trouver tonga et puis vint le
coup mais en fait ce qui est impossible
c'est déjà accusé une leçon mais oui
georges maman pense que c'est lui ça
dépasse l'imaginable c'est moi qui lui
ai dit quoi
oui on a été complètement citronnée
photographe en soit il est assez quoi
pensent des formes tout ça ah oui je
défends villa ou une bouche pour dire
qu'il est à vous et moi un fouet bah oui
il est comme toi mais il est fou mais
non il n'est pas fou il invite à deux
états dans la peau il devrait couvrir
tout est mensonge
non mais dis tu es boucher ou quoi la
france la mangue alpin mais écoute moi
je tends vieux le poème enfin je suis là
devant une gamme d'autres comme trois
pommes tirer les ficelles de cette
banque helaba break partout et tout ça
pourquoi enfin pour faire son petit
effet pour jouer les apprentis libre
avait reçu en fin août à lille a vu ma
part qu'on prêtait se voulait un classe
9e se bat on attend
dany
mais tu attends birago salade amis
ah non bon écoute dany dit moi la vérité
cause de promesses rapport à personne je
t'assure que ce sera un secret entre toi
et moi hein tu le dis et je la boucle
d'accord bon nani t'attend egos
mais à quoi je voudrais je ne sais pas
alors explique toi enfin on écoute dany
daniel tu veux manger moi moi moi j'aime
ça dit il faut que je prenne
zani pourquoi veux-tu un petit pb
j'en ai envie c'est physique physique
bah oui enfin c'est comme si tu avais
feinte avait soif non abbas et morale
enfin c'est le chili qui tue près de dix
heures syriens tués en bête avec pt sa
vie dont celle ci fixe à soigner j'ai de
plus en plus l'impression que tu as
besoin d'être soigné tu crois pas que ça
les autres qu'on devrait soigner non
mais moi je suis parfaitement normal je
suis jeune je veux vivre
tu sais ce que ça veut dire vivre être
heureuse avoir un truc à soi rien qu'à
soir tu t'en fous toi tu as ton noir
castres tu as pin qui plus est avec une
fille comme moi je veux un gosse non tu
comprends pas ça je suis ici parce que
je me demande c'est comment cette idée a
pu devenir
au début j'en avais tellement envie que
je me suis imaginé des trucs un garçon
très très très beau
qui venaient me voir le soir ils
entraient par le jardin par là tu vois
j'attendais sont pas sans drogue
je compté jusqu'à 20 et je me disais ça
y est le voilà il s'asseyait sur mon lit
il me prenait la main il me disait bon
ben je crois que c'est pas la peine que
j'aille plus loin monsieur est cartésien
sais pas si tu veux à force d'y penser
j'ai fini par y croire voilà tous nous
sommes devant un corps de mythomanie
infantile et
tu parles il ya longtemps que vous
m'avez ramené à la réalité à la réalité
oui au début elle était très jolie mon
histoire
j'aurais dû en parler à personne c'est
vous qui me l'avait caché et tu sais ce
qui s'est passé ben non eh bien je me
suis dit puisque personne ne me
comprends puisque personne ne me croit
eh bien je vais la rendre au havre est
mon histoire vraiment vrai et j'ai
essayé mais qu'est ce que tu as essayé
la pauvreté astia j'ai demandé teddy qui
n'a pas voulu
gilbert n'ont plus personne n'a marché
effarant heureusement qui tombait sur
des copains enfin surtout sur mes
copains landes à nu tout ça tu as pas de
lui et c'est justement parce que je veux
voir quelque chose qui tienne vraiment
bout que je veux sans que tu voulais que
je fais at il averti approché pour des
conneries tu sais je sais que c'est mme
ebadi la porte à clé écoute moi bien je
compte de mesures de sécurité trois fois
oui il moi une chose est ce que je suis
mort
non nous pas 16 ans
ce qui est à toi je fiche le camp d'ici
moteur non tu trouves je trouve que j'en
ai pas ça c'est supporter il ya des
limites mais cette fois c'est fini avec
des gens normaux qu'est ce que la en
cours celle là elle s'en va c'est pas
possible
mais c'est la gare d'austerlitz dans
cinq minutes tout le monde est à bloc
dominique je m'en fais tu ne vas pas
faire ça les plus absolus mans utile que
tu fasses un gramme
ma décision est présent gérer que des
villes passées j'ai s'est rien passé
il ya tellement que j'en ai assez de
cette comédie je ne peux plus la
supporter et porter quoi quoi tu me
demande quoi c'est un enfer ici mais je
ne veux pas tu t'en ailles pas
aujourd'hui
pourquoi pas aujourd'hui mon père tu
savais
comme je te dirai rien je ne suis pas
comme ça moi tu comprendra plus tard
calme toi personne ne m'aime
vous voulez tous me faire du mal mais
non non non moi je ne sers à rien je
fais mon année à mais pas du tout tu vas
rester que ces gains de nuit a besoin de
toi non comment nous mais plus
maintenant
georges voiles et pousser les poux 6
cellules il pèse novosti et qu'est ce
qu'il a ce petit truc bizarre exercice
de mystère tout est arrangé mexique toi
mais génial a expliqué du tout j'ai pris
le problème en main levée solutionner
c'est tout dany n'a rien fait de mal
enfin pas encore quant au petit moineau
mais s'est envolé eh bah tant mieux si
j'avais rencontré ce volatile dans
l'appartement j'aurais immédiatement les
familles
un moineau une tortue pourquoi pas une
girafe françois tu habitais pinky pour
le week end sourit elle vient la fin
prêt vous n'allez pas faire une chose
pareille
pourquoi dans ma chair in cette petite
et charmante elle est beaucoup mieux que
son fiancé
cette petite et la fiancée de françois
vous ne pensez tout de même pas que
c'était la mienne je les prises comme
hautain
si tu n'es pas sage e sophie retourne
aux herbes à l'offre et non en résidence
surveillée
[Musique]
et oui quand même
alors dominique amory car quel honneur
pour nous bonne soirée 200 milliards
pardon j'ai catoire maire j'arrivais pas
à boucler mes valises les valises
je pars avec un camarade sur les bords
du lac de pau françois reyne cette
musique dégénérée et dia table le boudin
apportez le chez toi de ne pas gagner
tout le reste ici une minute
cet individu en vitesse je n'ai pas tout
à fait fini j'aimerais de temps en temps
pour voir faire un repas tran pire
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs la pièce que nous
avons eu l'honneur et le plaisir de
jouer devant vous et de michel fermaud
là des corps de roger hart
et avec la distribution suivante yvonne
clech
corinne le poulain
[Musique]
jean louis philippe
rosine fabec
[Applaudissements]
evelyne valentino
michel gonzalez
la trivalle liés
il a une vieille d'année
et le metteur en scène christian gérard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
oh
à